[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning the sooner we finish the better
the words of president biden last night
as he said the us is on course to end
evacuations from kabul by tuesday
this morning reports that the uk's
evacuation flights may have to stop this
week after boris johnson failed to
secure an extension to the deadline for
western forces to leave but he is keen
for the taliban to secure the safe
passage of refugees from the country
plenty then to discuss with the foreign
secretary dominic wrap in just a couple
of moments also on the programme
going all the way to highlight plastic
pollution i'll be speaking to the
swimmer and environmental campaigner
ollie rush as he becomes just the fifth
person to swim around the isle of wight
also heads
[Music]
we're going to be joined by steven
schwartz one of theater's most
successful composers as the west end
pays tribute to the man responsible for
some of their biggest ever hits it is
wednesday 25th of august
kabul countdown reports this morning
that the uk's evacuation flights from
afghanistan may need to stop by the end
of the week as president biden says the
us is on course to finish operations by
august the 31st
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
[Music]
on the grounds in the air and at sea sky
news on patrol with french police funded
by the uk
as they try to stop migrants from
crossing the channel
ecosystem engineers whites hope the
reintroduction of beavers into the
english countryside could be good for
the environment
off to a winning start dame sarah's
story wins her 15th ever gold to give
great britain their first medal at the
tokyo paralympics
and the tributes keep rolling as the
biggest names in music salute drummer
charlie watts
and once again it looks like it's going
to be another fine and dry day for some
temperatures could get up to 28 degrees
celsius i'll have the details for you
later
morning all in a late night's press
conference at the white house president
biden repeated his intention for us
troops to end the rescue operation at
kabul airport thousands of people are
leaving afghanistan every day to escape
the new taliban regime
the us leader rejected proposals from g7
leaders including the prime minister to
extend operations beyond the current
deadline of august the 31st reports this
morning say uk flights may well stop by
the end of the week we'll be speaking to
the foreign secretary in just a couple
of minutes but first this report from
our u.s correspondent mark stone
each leader had their own image from the
virtual g7 meeting and together the idea
was a show of strength and unity there
has after all been little of either this
past week
led by boris johnson the consensus was
to persuade president biden that more
time was needed to complete the
withdrawal they wanted an extension to
the august 31st deadline the american
president disagreed we are currently on
a pace to finish by august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
of course invidious as it may be
delaying the u.s departure wasn't a
decision president biden could make
without a guarantee from the taliban
that it would continue to cooperate with
america the president is being advised
from the ground that an attack against
coalition forces is a growing danger
and from the taliban spokesman the
message couldn't have been clearer
and after that
it's something that's been against the
agreement
all people should be removed prior to
that date and that is why dialogue
between america their intermediaries and
the taliban is absolutely key it's
striking that it was the cia director
who met the leader of the taliban this
week in kabul that shows just how high
level these talks are the qataris will
also play a key role in the days ahead
my understanding is that they are doing
all they can if not to extend that
deadline then at least to allow safe
passage of people to continue after the
americans have left
[Music]
in the absence of any progress there the
british prime minister is looking longer
term we've got together the the leading
western powers and agreed
not just a
joint approach to dealing with the the
evacuation but also a road map for the
way in which we're going to engage
with
the taliban yet from the un's human
rights chief a grim assessment of the
reality summary executions of civilians
and all the combat members of the afghan
national security forces
restrictions on the right of women
including the right to move around
freely and girl's right to attend school
recruitment of child soldiers and
repression of peaceful protests and
expression of descent
the u.s president has been consistent
throughout this process holding his
position through such chaos
now it is the taliban apparently calling
the shots over the coalition withdrawal
mark stone sky news at the white house
uh very pleased to say once again joined
in the studio by the foreign secretary
dominic wrap mr rob good to see you this
morning good morning um clearly there's
an awful lot to discuss in terms of
afghanistan moving forward but but we do
need to to go back to last week to the
tail end of last week
on friday
kabul was was we now know 48 hours from
being taken over by the taliban you
spoke to the prime minister from your
holiday on friday what was the content
of that conversation well look i'm not
going to go into all of the details
those are private conversations but what
we were overwhelmingly focused on with
the cobra meetings the meetings i had
with the director running the emergency
response and indeed the international
engagement that i was focused on is two
things securing the airport so that
flights evacuation flights could come in
and out secondly boosting our teams on
the ground we now have 19 foreign office
officials many home office officials so
we can process not just the uk nationals
but the afghans who worked for us and i
would just say this if you look from
that date forward over 9 000 people have
been
given safe passage to the uk i don't
think there's been an airlift on that
scale that level of complexity in living
memory indeed and we will we will dwell
on that as well during this interview
but you were three days away on friday
from from making your way back to the
united kingdom
on sunday evening
indeed sorry apologies too
what was the intelligence assessment on
friday of how long it would take the
taliban to take over the capital of
afghanistan well i don't go into the
specific intelligence but we not we
don't discuss intelligence matters and
operational assessments but i can tell
you this uh and it's been clear all
along clearly the scale and pace of the
fall of kabul came as a surprise to
everyone around the world not just
western powers like the uk and the us
but when i was speaking to the qataris
the pakistanis i think even the taliban
was surprised but of course we can learn
those lessons with hindsight we dealt
with the reality that we saw it but in
terms of the the conversation that you
had with the prime minister had you been
ordered to come back to the united
kingdom to be at your desk for the fall
of of kabul did you lobby the prime
minister to be to work remotely
all of those claims and suggestions
we discussed the matter i agreed to come
back on sunday i'm not going to add
further uh to the speculation around
that but the idea uh some of the
reporting some of the assertions you put
to me just not true but we were focused
overwhelmingly on securing the airport
making sure and i was engaged in
meetings the the stuff about me being
lounging around the beach all day just
nonsense
there's stuff about me paddleboarding
nonsense the sea was actually closed it
was a red notice i was focused on the
cobra meetings the foreign office team
the director and the director general
and the international engagement and as
a result of the actions of the
government 9 000 people
british nationals afghan workers were
secured back to the uk but the reason
this is significant is demonstrated by a
poll in the mail this morning which
shows a majority of people want you to
lose your job for not coming back from
your holiday the fact that as the
commons debate demonstrated there are
people within your own party who feel
the government was disinterested in what
was going on in the ground you were on
holiday the prime minister was on
holiday the permanent secretary of the
foreign office was on holiday the
minister responsible for afghanistan was
on holiday
self-selecting reader polls in uh
newspapers i'm afraid uh are not a
particularly accurate barometer um but
in terms of what we're doing at all
material times so because foreign
secretary of course with the benefit of
hindsight i wouldn't have gone away but
that's a luxury of commentators not
politicians and if you're the foreign
secretary i'm traveling all the time
for work purposes i always need to be
able to grip uh crises that arise and
that's what we were doing do you regret
not coming back earlier look of course i
said with the benefit of hindsight i
would have been back earlier but we were
all surprised by the scale and the pace
of uh the collapse of the situation in
kabul and as i said
i was still doing all the things you
would need me to do to focus on what
really mattered engaging in the cobra
meetings but critically securing ramping
up the foreign office presence in kabul
and working with the mod ben wallis the
home secretary to make sure we could not
just secure the airport but get the
people home we got over 9 000 people
home since that point in time and i do
think that demonstrates that we were on
the job just in terms of of where we are
with the repatriation course it's
reported this morning that
you've briefed mps that that in essence
all british nationals all mono nationals
people with just single british
citizenship are basically out of the
country is that accurate so there's a
whole range of cases but basically uh
mono nationals so single nationality uk
who have got documentation the line
share almost all of them that want to
come out have been uh brought home the
ones that are remaining and we're uh
we've done an amazing job two and a half
thousand uk nationals if you go back to
april and remember it was in april it's
not just all starting in august where we
said you must leave the country you
should leave the country we'll support
you to do so so we've seen two and a
half thousand british nationals come
back what remains are rather complex
cases large family units where one or
other may be documented or maybe a
clearly national but it's not clear
whether the rest of them are so we've
got a great team on the ground in kabul
and in king charles street in the fcdo
checking and getting all of those
residual cases on where they're eligible
obviously again for intelligence reasons
you will not be able to put a specific
time on when we will be out of
afghanistan i understand that there are
however suggestions
that the withdrawal could begin in as
little as 24 to 48 hours can you comment
on that well look for precisely the
reason you gave i'm not going to give
the precise time and what we do know is
that we're working towards the end of
the month the military planners will
work out how much time they need to
withdraw their equipment their staff and
what what's really important is we'll
make the maximum use of all the time we
have left just to give you a sense now
in the last 24 hours i checked the
numbers coming in we've secured uh 2 000
back to the uk so the system is
operating at full speed uh at full
capacity and we'll use every last
remaining hour and day to get everyone
we can back the british nationals the
afghans who were so loyally for us we're
getting the achieving scholars back uh
also women's rights defenders and
journalists indeed um but but just in
terms of the timeline given that
everyone from the prime minister down i
think you've said this as well has has
basically made it clear that our
military presence on the ground in kabul
is predicated on the americans being
there as well we will have to come out
before they do
it is fair to say isn't it then on the
basis of that timeline that we may well
be out by the end of the weekend well we
we'll work to the end of august but
we'll take back from that you step back
from that the time that we need to
withdraw our military operation uh the
military planners are firming that up i
can't give you the precise details um
because we want to we want to make sure
we use every last hour and day to keep
this rate up and we've done it
and again i just stressed the teams on
the ground and in king charles street
the emergency response center did an
amazing job since april since april over
11 000 people given safe passage back to
the uk it's never been done before and
no country has done better we know that
there will be people who will not be
able to make it back before the august
31st deadline again suggestions this
morning that in some fashion kabul
international airport could continue to
see people leaving on civilian flights
and we had conversations with the
taliban about the possibility of this we
do engage with the taliban militarily on
the ground and in doha with the
political representation i think the uh
we would we would like to see a cable
airport go back to being functional that
will require on the security the the
security on the ground
it'll require it to be done safely and
of course it'll require the taliban to
live up to their assurances about
allowing safe passage out they've
actually so far
tried to be constructive as we've seen
with the numbers we've got and trying to
be constructed in their own way um and
what we've then got to do is test uh
them uh beyond the withdrawal date will
they still allow safe passage as they've
undertaken will they allow humanitarian
groups the permissive environment to be
able to operate
so there is a next stage of engagement
not recognition engagement with the
taliban we will hold them very clearly
to the assurances that they're already
stating but we heard it yesterday though
the head of the cia traveled to kabul to
meet with the taliban directly has
something similar happened with the head
of mi6 as richard moore held any
meetings with the taliban richard
moore's the head of mi6 not mi5
but we will engage diplomatically as
well as through the military presence on
the ground i won't say too much more but
i do think what i would say now is it's
important that we can convey our
messages directly and one of the ways
that we've been able to handle this
pretty
epic
evacuation is by being able to engage
and convey clear messages i do think
that's important and we want to make
sure there's some continuity to that but
just can you at least give us a sense
that the uk spy chief is
engaging directly with the taliban
trying to help secure the mission i'm
not going to comment on either c or the
natural depth of our engagement but as i
mentioned of course on the ground in
relation to the airport we engage with
their their british troops the taliban
cheek and jail and also via the
political commission which is based in
doha we make sure that we can engage
speaking to your colleague ben wallace
yesterday i mean he made it pretty clear
obviously the security situation around
the airport is is pretty severe
and the closer we get to august the 31st
the greater the risk of of some form of
attack on on the allied forces there is
it your understanding that islamic
states al-qaeda any of those other
groups are are extant in afghanistan at
the moment are operational in
afghanistan i think we're also concerned
about the way the prisons were emptied
by the taliban so of course that means
that we're
ever vigilant about that potential risk
clearly one of the key things that we're
saying to the taliban is first of all to
continue the safe passage of people
about british nationals and others
we are they're saying the taliban
spokesman said yesterday he wanted to
avoid the brain drain well actually in
that case they're going to need to be a
lot more tolerant and inclusive than
they've been before um
and of course the number one thing for
us beyond safe passage will be making
sure afghanistan is never used as a base
for terrorism again and the taliban has
said that they're committed to that
what are the levers we can use to exert
some form of influence of the taliban
you yourself have written about the
potential for sanctions we know however
that you know perhaps as much as 60
of the afghan state budget comes from
money from from overseas if we are to
turn off the tax in terms of the money
we will see an even greater humanitarian
catastrophe won't we there is look
there's always the risk with sanctions
that you need to target them in a way
that protects the civilians and and
deals with the individuals that you want
to hold to account there's a whole range
of things the amount of aid that they'll
need
the access to the international
financial system billions of pounds the
taliban are saying they do not want
whole economy and social uh fabric such
as it is in afghanistan to collapse that
gives us leverage on them in relation to
those chaos safe passage out
never to allow afghanistan to be used
for terrorism and indeed the permissive
environment that they will need to
provide if they want the un ngos to
operate in afghanistan if they don't
we're not going to give aid the taliban
we would only do it via those third
parties
of course the g7 yesterday made it very
clear look taken together we have an
awful lot of economic and diplomatic
clout however
look at those countries which still have
an embassy open on the ground there
russia china if afghanistan strikes
bilateral deals with them that does make
it rather more difficult for the g7 to
exert its efforts doesn't it well first
of all i think pm was absolutely right
take the lead use the g7 presidency get
the g7 together and the statement was uh
pretty thorough a starting point for the
way forward but you're right we need a
broader group of countries i've been
speaking to my chinese opposite number
we are pressing the russians as well and
indeed the countries in the region i've
spoken to the indian the pakistani
foreign ministers if we want to exert
maximum moderating influence on the
taliban such as it is with all due
skepticism we're going to need to
operate in a greater a broader caucus
that's one of the reasons why we're
pressing for a meeting of the permanent
five
members of the security council which
includes china russia as well as france
the uk and the us uh in the coming days
to provide at least the contours of a
way forward that we can all agree on uh
a lot for you to be getting on with so
we'll let you go on with the dominic ram
kitchen to talk to you
uh no let's turn to our correspondent
sally lockwood who's joining us from
doha morning sally i'm clearly you had
the foreign secretary they're talking
about the taliban uh talking again uh
just give us an idea of what you're
hearing in the region this morning
well qatar of course has become a really
pivotal player in what's happening in
afghanistan not only receiving hundreds
thousands
of evacuees and there's no cap on how
many they're prepared
to receive as i understand it but
they're also already helping with talks
between former afghan government
officials and also the taliban trying to
broker some sort of unity government as
to what the country will do next in
terms of how it moves forward and how
it's run
i met yesterday i should say i met
yesterday a former
a senior u.s military officer just by
chance i asked him how are you how are
things going he got very emotional as he
tried to answer that question let's not
forget the people that are involved in
this evacuation here there's a huge u.s
military presence here in qatar helping
with this evacuation humanitarian crisis
that's unfolding in afghanistan it's
deeply personal for so many of those
members of the military on the ground at
the airport trying to clear up the chaos
that's unfolded in the last week or so
now of course one of the reasons that
president biden has shown no interest
yet in extending that 31st
of august deadline is because the
taliban have made it clear that that is
a red line for them but also we're
watching the taliban working very
closely with u.s british troops on the
ground at the airport they're
cooperating for now but we were warned
in an interview by the taliban here in
qatar that there would be consequences
if we were to stay beyond that 31st of
august deadline so many members of the
military have already been through so
much in afghanistan they've lost friends
they've lost limbs there this is deeply
personal and i think president biden is
all too aware that leaving them on the
ground beyond the 31st of august think
something could very something very uh
significant could change in terms of
their relationship with the taliban and
expose military troops
satellite we will talk again later in
the programme for now many thanks
but plenty still to come on the
programme i will be paying tribute to
the rolling stones drummer charlie watts
with music journalist david sinclair at
quarter to eight
we'll be getting plenty of reaction to
the morning's interview with the foreign
secretary at five past eight we'll be
joined by this man uh shadow defense
secretary john keane
a survey by sky sports news suggests
that nearly a third of football fans
from ethnically diverse communities who
attend games have experienced racist
abuse edwin john from the fa will be
here at 20 minutes
now sky news has been given access to
the french patrols funded by uk
taxpayers trying to stop the flow of
migrants across the channel and despite
repeated pledges by the home secretary
and tens of millions of pounds being
spent the numbers making the journey
continue to rise critics claim that
french police and border officials just
aren't doing enough our europe
correspondent michelle clifford has this
special report
from the darkness of the calais coast a
french special police team prepares to
break cover
for this
they've been tracking men they believe
to be migrants and asylum seekers
planning to cross the channel the group
take off
the police pursuit is not about
arresting the men but halting the next
stage of their journey intercepting the
small boats they would have made the
crossing in it was just about with that
motor only uh
commodity ram
only
this boat was almost certainly provided
by smugglers who will have been paid
thousands by those determined to make it
to uk shores
nearby what appears to be a child's
inflatable both taken away by the team
part funded by uk money
the following morning in sky news is on
board a plane scouring the calais coast
for signs of potential cross-channel
journeys
the pilot spots what he thinks of
migrants or asylum seekers on the beach
police are also alerted to a parked
vehicle with a boat attached and a
search begins for potential smugglers
they and the boats are the target of
this joint french uk operation stop them
the pilot says and people won't be put
in danger
the
[Music]
those who attempt the journey have
usually taken huge risks just to get to
french shores many escaping war others
poverty but the uk government is
determined to stem what it calls the
illegal trafficking people across the
channel and has handed millions in
recent months to the french to fund
operations on land in the air and at sea
we travel out with the maritime police
who regularly spot boats dangerously
overloaded with people they tell us the
smuggler's tactic is to try to send
multiple vessels out at once making it
difficult for officers to keep track on
them all and at sea there are limits on
what the police can actually do
many on the uk side have accused the
french of not doing enough to stop
migrants and asylum seekers crossing the
channel but once people are actually in
boats and out at sea the objective of
the police is simply to preserve life
even if that means trailing some would
say escorting boats towards uk waters
the french insists they have no legal
right to turn boats back they can only
offer help if needed a position which
has infuriated ministers in britain and
led many to question why the uk
government is funding these operations
at all
[Music]
[Music]
despite the round-the-clock work on the
french side to thwart the smugglers
record numbers of people have made it
across the channel in small boats so far
this year the threat from the uk side of
harsher penalties for those who enter
illegally seemingly little deterrent
michelle clifford sky news cali
all right now also this morning 12
miners are reported to have been killed
after an accident in colombia
they were working underground in the
topaga region when the shaft they were
in was destroyed by a methane explosion
the government says it believes the
reintroduction of beavers into the wild
in england could help fight climate
change they've launched a consultation
which could lead to more of them being
released after becoming virtually
extinct more than 400 years ago
and you can keep up to date with all the
stories affected by the global climate
on the daily climate show that's right
here on sky news every weekday half past
six and half past night
some of the biggest names in music have
been paying tribute to the rolling
stones drummer charlie watts
uh sir elton john called him the
ultimate drummer on his twitter page the
most stylish of men uh elton telling his
followers it was a very sad day
the stone's front man mick jagger shared
just a single photo of charlie watts at
his drum kit
feeling no need to add any words
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning say hi to the high the high
pressure that will be sticking around
for the rest of this week keeping the
weather fine and settled for most of the
uk and ireland in fact for some it's
going to be locally very warm today
particularly across western parts of
scotland temperatures will be high as
well across parts of northern ireland
north west england and respectable
elsewhere quite a cloudy start for the
northeast of scotland where it stays
cloudy this afternoon with murky
conditions some light rain and drizzle
and also it will take some time for it
to brighten up around central and
eastern parts of england but eventually
it will become brighter there but at the
same time eastern coastal counties of
england will become increasingly cloudy
breezy there but elsewhere mostly fine
dry bright and
the
warm
sponsored by qatar airways
uh it's still to come we'll get the very
latest live from afghanistan and here
again from the foreign secretary dominic
ram coming away in just a couple of
hours
[Music]
we couldn't give you a number in terms
of how many are suffering from mental
health problems purely because it's not
something that's really talked about
within the industry
there's certainly a degree of stigma in
what is still quite a macho industry
but everyone is suffering everyone is
finding it hard everyone has had changes
to terms and conditions and income and
it's it's a really tough time for
aviation it just hasn't bounced back
we think about aviation as a as a
community
as almost a vacation
and being a pilot is so much part of
people's identity that when they aren't
at work when they aren't flying as often
as they used to be they lose that
massive amount of their identity because
it takes so long and so much commitment
so much money to become a pilot
that it's so much of
who somebody is so pilots together have
launched as you say this text service
with shout 85258
and this is a crisis service which
allows pilots regardless of their
employment status
to text in and
just discuss anything that they're
struggling with
beyond that we do an awful lot as a
charity
to support people financially in terms
of as i say the community
retraining but overall um the industry
as i say is a really challenging one in
terms of getting pilots to speak up
about their mental health at all
so this crisis service is something that
we really hope will help people
just be able to to speak up to to say
that they're having a tough time
you can realistically say that pilots
are struggling in exactly the same way
as everybody else
um
we are all human we all suffer from
exactly the same things that everybody
else in every other industry is
suffering from it's just that
traditionally we don't have
a culture of speaking about mental
health challenges and that's something
we really want to change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back the 2020 paralympics are
underway in tokyo full of excitement
about this uh we'll be getting you at
more detail of great britain's first
medal in just a few minutes but let's
focus on how day one went joining us
from tokyo once again nbc's sports
reporter heather hogan heather good to
see you again so day one done how did it
go
it went great so far so good neil thank
you tonight kicks off the first final
session here at the tokyo aquatic center
as one of the most decorated paralympic
swimmers in history brazil's daniel diaz
begins his metal pursuit here in the
men's 200 free he has announced that
tokyo 2020 will be his last games as he
hopes to add to his impressive
collection of 24 paralympic medals as
for what's already happened in a
wheelchair rugby nicknamed murderball
due to its extreme physicality the
rivalry between australia and the united
states is expected to be as fierce as
ever australia who won gold in this
event in rio is in search of a
three-peat here in tokyo and today they
open against denmark in pool play now
how about some wheelchair basketball a
hugely popular sport here in japan on
the woman's side the reigning gold
medalists team usa were upset in their
opening game earlier today losing
68-58 to the netherlands meanwhile the
women of team gb are in search of their
first ever medal in wheelchair
basketball led by robin love who
believes quote the paralympics is about
thriving through diversity and adversity
team gb will take on home team japan
tomorrow in its first game together in
18 months
heather comprehensive as always keep
enjoying yourself we'll speak again very
very soon thanks for now
and if you've never watched murder ball
seriously give it a go it's fantastic
now the foreign secretary dominic rapp
has denied claims that he continued his
foreign holiday as the taliban sees
power in afghanistan
president biden has again insisted u.s
troops will leave by august the 31st as
thousands still try to leave the capital
kabul
a short time ago mr rabb told me that
claims he refused to come back to the uk
sooner were untrue
we discussed the matter i agreed to come
back on sunday i'm not going to add
further uh to the speculation around
that but the idea uh some of the
reporting some of the assertions you put
to me just not true but we were focused
overwhelmingly on securing the airport
making sure and i was engaged in
meetings that the the stuff about me
being lounging around the beach all day
just nonsense the stuff about me
paddleboarding nonsense the sea was
actually closed it was a red notice
our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen uh was lurking in the wings
listening to that interview and tomorrow
what more did we learn apart from of
course that the sea was closed that day
well dominic rob very defensive about
how much work he was doing on that
holiday and to claims that the
government was asleep at the wheel 48
hours before the fall of kabul he the
prime minister the senior civil servant
of that department and his junior
minister all on holiday as the taliban
made their lightning advance and
essentially what dominic raab was saying
was that he was fully engaged in all the
cobra meetings that the prime minister
spoke to him on friday and they agreed
he would come back sunday and that no
time was lost in terms of the the
evacuation he says that no country has
done better in getting their nationals
out and the pace has increased so much
he said that in the last 24 hours 2 000
people have got out he was
unsurprisingly cagey about exactly how
much longer we may have left conditions
on the ground
are very uncertain of course you don't
want to cause even more panic among a
very desperate group of people but
certainly the message is there is not
long to go now and they're pulling all
the stops out to try and get everyone
who it has been processed onto those
planes and if they can't get onto the
planes now hopefully try and secure ways
for them to get out later just on that
topic the the airport kabul
international airport we asked the
foreign secretary about the potential of
civilian flights i mean so much of that
depends on the the taliban themselves
don't we already know we were speaking
to sally lockwood about it just a few
minutes ago that they are becoming
increasingly concerned about the brain
drain that in essence is ongoing yes and
the talk about evacuating now judges
journalists human rights advocates
they are they're taking out so many
people and he says the taliban are
concerned about it and that we do have
leverage because we have billions of
dollars in western bank accounts that
can be used to try and hold them to some
of these promises but as we saw
yesterday boris johnson asking the u.s
president for an extension of the troops
being there failing to get that a lot of
this is going to hinge on the west
working together towards particular
goals and no one really knows how
engaging with the taliban is going to go
yes we can hold money against them but
how much they'll want to cooperate with
that process is still very much unknown
oh certainly is uh tomorrow thank you
uh but let's
let's return to afghanistan and the
commitment by president biden to end the
rescue operation at kabul airport by
august the 31st
means uncertainty for those still trying
to escape so far around 70 000 have
managed to leave but thousands more
are still hoping to get out
uh
zadran is a student in afghanistan and
was the country's youth representative
at the united nations last year and she
joins us on the program good to see you
this morning and i wonder
given what we have been hearing over the
past few days from in and around
afghanistan how you are feeling about
the taliban takeover of your country
well thank you very much for having me
uh as a as a
citizen uh that's this is very clear
that uh i am still in a state of
disbelief and shock uh we have lost
everything that we have uh
struggled for since past two decades
and uh when the afghanistan and the
kabul was collapsed by taliban it was a
very dark and sad day for every afghan
especially for
especially for of one youth who
have been a main part of the recent
developments and the recent
achievements
so
i'm feeling sad but
i believe that we need to accept the
reality uh
we need to adjust ourselves with uh with
the circumstances and we need to
uh amplify our uh voices for uh better
changes and betterments uh
for our society and generation
what though does this new taliban
government mean for for for women like
yourself you were attending university
do you think there is any potential for
that to continue
well um uh considering their recent uh
uh press release and press conferences
uh their spokes spokesperson zavilam
has said that uh they are going to
respect uh
upon women's rights and freedoms and
they are going to allow one woman to
continue their
career and jobs and education but uh you
know i i believe that uh we still need
time to uh to to be sure that they are
actually
uh uh doing what they are saying uh
we we really really need assurance from
uh from them and from international
community that there will be no uh
compromises when it comes to a one
woman's right right
do you attribute any blame uh for what
we are seeing in and around kabul and in
afghanistan at the moment to the united
states to the united kingdom
um
i believe that uh each and every party
involved in past two decades war of
afghanistan is responsible for whatever
happened
in afghanistan to have one people
uh
since past two decades uh nato united
states of america and its allies have uh
uh
they have came to afghanistan with a
mission of counter-terrorism and
maintaining peace and order and law in
afghanistan but in past two decades they
have committed miserable war crimes
and now at this era of time at this
point of time they have left advance
to a very uncertain uh destiny uh they
they
did not fulfill their promises and their
responsibilities towards their wants the
unwise and immediate uh decision of
withdrawal and now that they are uh they
are just dealing with the taliban uh
totally ignoring the uh needs and
concerns of iran
uh all of this is a an indication that
uh they have been uh they are they were
not actually our strategic partners and
i i i strongly believe as a
as a one
youth representative to the united
nations i strongly believe that uh we
have been betrayed and we have been
we have been
sold out by everyone by international
community by united states of america
and by our own political leaders
school just a final question to you do
you see yourself remaining in
afghanistan in the long term
see
i have always said that i really really
want to stay here i
i don't want to leave my country but it
depends on the circumstances
it will depend on the situation
if i feel that i'm being
i'm being
i can be
i can contribute to this
country i can serve my people and they
are allowing me to stay here
to stay safe and to stay
productive here
then i will never leave my country i
don't want to leave my country i don't
want to leave my people but everything
is dependent on this
situation and whether they are
really
a lot
meaningfully
participate
in
we really want uh meaningful inclusion
uh into everything uh and uh decision
makings so if that happens uh not only
me but every
one
woman will
love to stay here because this is our
country at the end of the day this is
our home
school
we have to leave it there but we wish
you well do stay safe and thank you so
much for talking to us
thank you very much for having me
uh still to come after the break
[Applause]
we'll be paying tribute to the rolling
stones drummer charlie watts with the
music journalist dave sinclair that's
coming next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line they are dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us get ready
instructing you to stay at home
[Applause]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they'll
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day can't access those and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong that was a
moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football
pitches shoeborn robins sky news bangkok
[Music]
do
[Music]
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
it'll be largely dry and fine today with
sunny spells for most places however
northeast scotland will be cloudy murky
and cool and it'll take a while for
central england to brighten up
later eastern coastal counties of the uk
will become cloudy too this will be a
warm day in the sunshine though
especially across western scotland so
taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 or with 10
being very high most places will stay at
a low level of one to three however with
light winds locally generated pollutants
may allow for isolated moderate levels
for central parts of scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now musicians have been paying tribute
to rolling stones drummer charlie watts
who died yesterday
[Applause]
well the 18 year old was of course one
of the longest serving members of the
band
sir elton john
described him as the ultimate drummer on
his twitter page he continued the most
stylish of men told his followers it was
a very sad day
our fellow drummer ringo starr course in
the beatles i said god bless charlie
watts sending peace and love to his
family
musician and co-songwriter for the
rolling stones keith richards just
shared this single picture an empty drum
kit no one behind it with that closed
sign at the front
similar
from the bandmate and frontman mick
jagger he shared this photo of the
musician
joining us now music journalist david
sinclair david great to see you this
morning hope you're well um
your thoughts on on the passing of
charlie watts clearly this was a figure
of huge significance in british music
and indeed in music just in general
well absolutely yeah one of the one of
the founders if you like of the whole
modern rock the generation and uh
it's a terrible wrench my feelings are
uh
you know we we all know the stones have
been going for nearly 60 years as the
same band and they're all approaching
their 80s but you sort of imagine that
they're indestructible somehow and
and for this to happen obviously it's
perfectly predictable but it's still a
terrible shock and uh i think my
feelings at the moment are just can this
be true you know but obviously it is
true it's very sad and um you kind of
look back on what he's done and what
he's achieved and what the band have
achieved through his
you know with his agent
and it's just a tremendous
story
uh and a tremendous uh sense of
loss at this great player that has gone
gone the way of all things
as often happens at times like this when
figures of such significance are lost
people have been sharing their stories
of charlie watts my director nobody
doesn't mind me mentioning this met him
at the airport and ended up going out
for dinner with the man you've
interviewed him yourself what was he
like
oh well he's a wonderfully uh he's a
wonderfully understated kind of
character actually considering the world
that he moved in
uh
unlike
keith richardson mick jagger he's he's
kind of a very sort of
calm and equitable sort of bloke you
know you'd sort of meet him and you'd
think wow this is the guy in the in the
greatest rock and roll band in the world
seriously
um but he had a kind of he had a twinkle
he had a great sort of sparkle in his
eyes
and he but he could be quite kind of
lugubrious you know he'd sort of always
play down the achievements of the band
his own abilities as a drummer he was
very modest man really
um
and he was always kind of very relaxed
you know you'd see me being this very
he'd always be very very stylishly
dressed
but he would slump in a sofa very
relaxed sort of way as if he was just
sort of having a just chewing the fat
over on a kind of sunny afternoon with
you and uh
it was an extraordinary mixture of
things really and uh
he he always seemed to be slightly apart
from the the mayhem and the madness of
the world that he inhabited
and uh it was always a very he was
always very genial very pleasant guy to
kind of come across but obviously
a great rock and roll star at the same
time a lot of charisma david what what
is what has surprised me is someone who
of course has known the work of the
rolling stones but whereas but certainly
not as not as not followed his career as
closely as people like you what has
surprised me is reading interviews with
them previous interviews is how often
dismissive he was about parts of the
back catalogue um that he did he kind of
wasn't ashamed of it but you know he
often commented that he'd rather be
playing some jazz at some points but you
know he was the person who provided the
backbeat the beat for some of the
greatest tunes that british musicians
have ever produced
well that's right exactly and i think
that was part of his appeal that he
never really bought into the whole myth
of the stones in the way that everybody
else does
uh he always seemed to regard it as a
bit of a lark you know he was very very
into his jazz music he made several solo
albums of his own
which was far more you know a lot
different from the stones music it was
jazz and that was his first love but
obviously his commitment to the band
could never ever be
in doubt he was in the in the band for
almost 60 years come on and he never let
them down once and he provided some pile
driving stuff i mean you know if you
think of the big hits of the stones
brown sugar and honky tonk women and
those tracks are just incredibly
rhythmically driven they're the tracks
that get everyone on the dance floor
straight away and that was his
contribution to the band the rhythmic
foundation
it was incredible but in terms of his
feeling about being a rock star and
being a member of the greatest rock and
roll band in the world and all that kind
of thing he just thought that was a lot
of nonsense he was he was very very sort
of uh
kept his kept his feet very much on the
ground in that sense david i'm afraid we
are going to have to leave it there good
to talk to you this morning thanks for
sharing your memories of charlie watts
good to see you time for us to have a
quick look at the weather
[Music]